ah yeah today we have a special lesson
with friends
featuring guest star brad pitt
so it was just thanksgiving and this is
a holiday that is celebrated by
virtually all americans
in which we come together with friends
and family
and have a big feast while we reflect on
things that we are grateful for over the
past year
and american series like friends often
do special episodes with these kind of
holidays
which makes them a great resource not
only to improve your english
but also to learn about american culture
so we're going to jump into the lesson
in just a sec but just in case you're
new here i wanted to let you know that
every single week
we make fun lessons like this one so
that you can understand fast speaking
natives
without getting lost without missing the
jokes and without subtitles
just like tate who says that thanks to
our lessons they can now speak
confidently with natives
and you can too all you have to do is
hit that subscribe button and the bell
down below so you don't miss
any of our new lessons and finally i
just wanted to let you know that we have
a special present to go along with this
video
it is this pdf power lesson which you
can
download and it's going to help you to
take your knowledge with this scene
to the next level so that you don't
forget anything that you learned today
you can download that down in the
description below so now
let's roll this scene with brad pitt on
friends
[Music]
happy thanksgiving ah thanks god will
i'm so glad that you came you just
you look great you must have lost like
150 pounds
yeah i'm gonna be in one of those subway
sandwich commercials
a pie right all right it's no fat it's
no sugar it's no dairy
it's no good throw it out you're gonna
meet some people
this is uh this is my husband chandler
chandler this is will hey
oh hey i'd shake your hand but uh i'm
really into the game
plus i think it'd be better for my ego
if we didn't stand right next to each
other
this is phoebe hi hey
well done gonna give me a hand
sure monica can't get over how great you
look you look stunning
you look incredible too you're just
you're so fit i'm watching the game but
i'm not
deaf oh um
i meant to tell you um ross is coming
well it's just come great i love ross oh
good
and rachel green too oh
is there a problem no uh
it's okay it's just uh god i hated her
what yeah i hated her she was horrible
to me in high school
but hey that was a long time ago i'm in
a good place it might be
actually fun to see her again you gotta
need cakes or cookies or something
no will no
[Music]
happy thanksgiving ah thanks god will
i'm so glad that you came
to be glad is to be happy and thankful
for something
this is also what we say when we hear
that something nice happened to someone
we care about
as in the following example i'm so glad
to hear that you got a promotion
you've really worked hard for it you
just you look great
you must have lost like 150 pounds
could you understand what monica said
here must have lost like
150 pounds if you didn't don't feel bad
about it because she said it really fast
she said you must have lost
the tricky connected speech aspect of
this utterance is the reduction of
have it's not must have but
must of or musta when did you start to
feel like a father oh
well i i guess it must have been
the day after you were born my god you
used to be so
i mean you you you must have lost like
you look great let's see how this same
thing happens with the modal verbs would
and should
instead of would have and should have
most times you'll hear
that would have been cool
i mean i should have seen it a pie
right all right it's no fat it's no
sugar it's no dairy
it's no good throw it out
dairy foods are those that are made from
milk such as yogurt
cream butter or cheese note this is
pronounced with an
s sound dairy brad pitt's character here
is showing his dissatisfaction with
healthy food
because all fat sugar and dairy are when
consumed in excess
bad for your health however these things
are also what make food delicious
so that's why he says it's no good i'd
shake your hand but
i'm really into the game plus i think
it'd be better for my ego if we didn't
stand right next to each other
when you're into something you're paying
full attention to something
example the movie lasted more than three
hours but i was so
into it that i didn't even realize it
was that long
another sense of this expression is when
you say you like or enjoy doing
something
he's into golf not because i'm i'm into
s
m i'm not into anything weird
just just normal sex
the joke here is that chandler feels
intimidated by how attractive will is
so that's why he doesn't want to shake
his hand
monica can't get over how great you look
you look stunning
saying i can't get over something is
another way of saying i'm just so amazed
example i can't get over how much weight
he lost in so little time
i just can't get over this coincidence i
mean what are the odds
the same weekend i come home missy let
it go
stunning is a stronger version of
impressive or beautiful
when describing a person this adjective
means extremely attractive
example the view from the hill is
absolutely stunning
as a verb you can also say you're
stunned by something or someone
in this case it could be by something
positive or
negative example the community was
stunned by the tragedy
so i really cannot express to you just
how thankful we are
to have over 1.25 million subscribers
from
every corner of the globe to show a bit
of our gratitude i wanted to let you
know
that for the next 48 hours we have a
special sale going on on our fluent with
friends course
in this 48 week course you will learn
like never before
as you follow along with the first two
seasons of the series friends
plus you get 20 plus page pdf power
lessons
vocabulary memorization software access
to our fluency circle global community
and so much more so for black friday
we have a tremendous 33 discount
available to you
on all the packages of our course this
is really going to help you in reaching
your goals
to confidently understand natives and
improve your fluency
so you can learn a ton more about this
course by clicking the link up here
or down in the description below and
remember to get your discount
just use the coupon code thank you at
checkout
and remember you have your pdf power
lesson that you can download for this
lesson
and this is actually one of the
resources that you get with the fluent
with a friends course
however it is for the full episodes you
will also find the link to that
down in the description below and now
let's get back to the lesson
i meant to tell you um ross is coming
ross has come great i love ross
to mean in this case means to have the
intention of doing something
sometimes we say i meant to tell you
when we realized we forgot to mention
something to someone
example this morning when i saw you i
meant to ask you something
the first good thing she gets me in
weeks how could you not give me the
message
i tell you i do enjoy guilt
but uh it wasn't me okay it was me
i i meant to kill you and i wrote it all
down on my hand see all of it
yep that's my audition if you say it in
the present perfect continuous
as in i've been meaning to ask you it
means that you've wanted to ask that
person something for a long time
but perhaps you haven't had the chance
to do it
there's something that i've been meaning
to tell you
yeah i hated her she was horrible to me
in high school
will is saying in an emphatic way that
rachel was mean or cruel to him
she didn't treat him well god i'm just a
horrible person
why because i'm married that's right i'm
a married woman
and i came to a tv star's apartment to
have an affair ah
that's ridiculous i'm not a star
just a regular famous actor
yeah and i'm a horrible horrible person
but hey it was a long time ago i'm in a
good place it might be
actually fun to see her again got any
cakes or cookies or something
to be in a good place is used to refer
to how a person is feeling emotionally
and about their life
example they had a difficult couple of
months but now they're in a good place
then he asks for something to eat this
is funny because a person that has
issues with food often eats when he or
she is anxious or stressed
even though he says he's okay now with
seeing rachel on the inside he's feeling
quite uneasy
about it
[Music]
well ross hey you came man
you look incredible hot stuff
that stuff it's good to see you man yeah
you too
man so so what are you up to i'm a
commodities broker
really yeah that that sounds interesting
yeah it's not
huh but i'm rich and thin whoa
man i i don't think i've seen you since
uh lance davis's graduation party that
was such a fun night yeah it would have
been good if we had gotten in but still
real fun god we were lame back then you
remember how into dinosaurs we were
yeah so what what do you do now
so how long are you in town
hi hey sweetie oh good here you go
rachel and green
oh oh that's right are you are you gonna
be okay well
i'll be fine just god i hate it ross i
can't
feed her
will high school was was a long time ago
look at her standing there with those
yams
my two greatest enemies ross rachel
green and complex carbohydrates
oh my god monica who is that
that's will from high school oh i do not
remember him
wow it's really got that sexy smoldering
thing going on
oh my god he's look at the way he's just
staring at me
i think he's trying to mount something
to me but i can't make it out
okay dinner's ready
hi will right right right hi
i'm rachel green oh i remember you
really
aren't you sweet i gotta tell you though
i am
i'm having the hardest time placing you
oh oh hang on i think i remember you did
we um
did we fool around at lance davis's
graduation party
you are unbelievable thank you
[Music]
man you look incredible hot stuff
that stuff it's good to see you man yeah
you too
hot stuff is used to describe a person
or something that is amazing popular or
even sexually exciting ross repeated hot
stuff
because he can't believe he said it
because it makes him sound gay
it's good to see you is what we commonly
say when greeting someone we haven't
seen in a long time
man so so what are you up to i'm a
commodities broker
really yeah that that sounds interesting
yeah it's not
uh what are you up to
or what have you been up to is what we
say to ask what someone is or has been
doing with their lives
during the time you haven't seen them
let's pay attention to how raw says it
oh so what are you up to compare what
are you up to
to what are you up to
we say this in two chunks what are you
up
two what are you up to oh we're just
hanging out
so what are you up to these days two is
pronounced with a strong form
two because it's at the end of the
sentence
this is different from when it's reduced
because it's in the middle of the
sentence
example i went to work and then tomorrow
morning you get to have christmas
morning in your own houses
which by the way none of you have
invited me to you can come to my house
by the way a commodity broker will's
profession
is an occupation that involves trading
or selling products for other people or
organizations a commodity is a substance
or
product that can be traded bought or
sold hey
so you can discover a lot more about the
american holiday of thanksgiving
and learn 11 native ways to say thank
you
in this lesson after you finish this
video that was such a fun night yeah it
would have been good if we had gotten in
but still
real fun notice here the same reduction
of
have after wood we discussed before
ross is saying they didn't get in
meaning they didn't enter the place
where the party took place
example the kids couldn't get into the
r-rated movie
god we were lame back then you remember
how into dinosaurs we were
lame means of poor taste or not
impressive
also sometimes used as a synonym for
pathetic
example this new song's lyrics are so
lame
then will says that liking dinosaurs was
and the funny thing is that he doesn't
know that ross went on to become a
paleontologist
someone who studies dinosaurs god i hate
a roster
sometimes we drop the h in her this also
happens in words such as he
him and his loved her so much i took her
everywhere
i would braid her tail look at her
standing there with those yams
a yam is a potato-like vegetable also
called a sweet potato
it is a staple at thanksgiving wow
really got that sexy smoldering thing
going on
to smolder is to burn slowly like a coal
that is burning out
but in this case it might mean that his
look
is burning with anger this isn't such a
common way to describe a look on
somebody's face
but rachel uses it to describe his
attractiveness
without realizing that he is looking at
her this way because he is an enraged
oh my god he's look at the way he's just
staring at me
i think he's trying to mount something
to me but i can't make it out
if you stare at someone you look at that
person for a
long period of time to mouth is to form
words with your lips without speaking
this is funny if you can make out what
he's saying
[Music]
in this case make out is to see and
identify something being communicated
example the music is too loud i can't
make out what you're saying
i gotta tell you though i'm i'm having
the hardest time placing you
the expression to have a hard time is
used to emphasize that someone finds
doing something difficult
example before discovering learning
english with tv she had the hardest time
understanding natives without subtitles
then if you can't play someone you may
recognize them but you can't remember
exactly who that person
is or where you have met them before
example
he looks very familiar but i cannot
place him right now
did we um did we fool around
at lance davis's graduation party you
are unbelievable
thank you
literally full round means to playfully
spend time in an unfocused
or unproductive manner but in this scene
it means that they made out or engaged
in other casual romantic or sexual
activities
will responds you're unbelievable
unbelievable can be used as a compliment
meaning something was so good that it's
hard to believe
here rachel thinks this is a
confirmation and a compliment
of how wonderful he thinks she is
however
will is actually frustrated in the
negative sense of this word
because he thinks it's absurd almost in
a way that he can't believe
that rachel forgot him and is confusing
him for somebody else
[Music]
happy thanksgiving ah thanks god will
i'm so glad that you came you just
you look great you must have lost like
150 pounds
yeah i'm gonna be in one of the subway
sandwich commercials
up high all right all right it's no fat
it's no sugar it's no dairy
it's no good throw it out you gonna meet
some people
this is uh this is my husband chandler
chandler this is will hey
oh hey i'd shake your hand but uh i'm
really into the game
plus i think it'd be better for my ego
if we didn't stand right next to each
other
this is phoebe hi hey
well done gonna give you a hand
sure monica can't get over how great you
look you look stunning
[Music]
you look incredible too you're just
you're so fit i'm watching the game but
i'm not deaf
oh um i meant to tell you um ross is
coming ross has come great i love ross
oh good
and rachel green too oh
is there a problem no uh
it's okay it's just uh god i hated her
what yeah i hated her she was horrible
to me in high school
but hey it was a long time ago i'm in a
good place it might be
actually fun to see her again you got
any cakes or cookies or something
no will no
[Music]
hey you came man you look incredible
hot stuff
that stuff it's good to see you man yeah
you too
man so so what are you up to i'm a
commodities broker
really yeah that that sounds interesting
yeah it's not
huh but i'm rich and thin whoa
man i don't think i've seen you since uh
lance davis's graduation party that was
such a fun night
yeah it would have been good if we had
gotten in but still real fun
god we were lame back then you remember
how into dinosaurs we were
yeah so what do you do now
so how long are you in town
hi hey sweetie oh good here we go
rachel and green
oh oh that's right are are you gonna be
okay well i'll i'll be fine
just god i hate it ross i can feed her
will high school was was a long time ago
look at her standing there with those
yams
my two greatest enemies ross rachel
green and complex carbohydrates
oh my god monica who is that
that's will from high school oh i do not
remember him
wow he's really got that sexy smoldering
thing going on
oh my god he's look at the way he's just
staring at me i think he's trying to
mount something to me but i can't make
it out
hi will right right right hi
i'm rachel green oh i remember you
really
aren't you sweet i got to tell you
though i am
i'm having the hardest time placing you
oh oh hang on i think i remember you did
we
um did we fool around at lance davis's
graduation party
you are unbelievable thank you
so thank you again for all of your
support we are just so proud to see
we've been able to help so many of you
with these fun lessons and remember if
you want to get that tremendous 33
discount on our fluent with friends
course that you have to use the coupon
code
thank you before december 1st and do you
want to know what happens
next in today's scene well we have an
old lesson where we see the conclusion
of this hilarious scene with brad pitt
on friends that you can check out here
and you might also like these other
lessons teaching you english with brad
pitt
and now it's time to go beyond the
classroom and live your english aha yeah